I want to take you to another story
that's developing this hour now
Ecuador's president Guillermo lasso has
dissolved Congress on Tuesday MPS began
impeachment procedures against the
president accusing him of corruption
Ecuador's Constitution allows the
president in certain circumstances to
dissolve parliament and at the same time
announce his own resignation
Ecuador needs a new political and social
pact to allow it to escape from the
serious political crisis the country is
in and which unfortunately is getting
worse day by day we need to move forward
to a solution that can give hope to
Ecuadorian families for a future of
well-being and stability
is joining us now from Ecuador's Capital
Quito so what happens now Alessandro
[Music]
hello Alessandro rampieti in Quito it's
Rob Matheson in Doha can you hear me
unfortunately we seem to have lost our
uh called our links to Alessandra we'll
try and get him back later in the
programs now in Haiti Al jazeer has
spoken exclusively to one of the
nation's most powerful gang leaders
Jenny charissier leads a Federation of
nine groups and is accusing politicians
of fueling violence he's been accused of
Human Rights abuses but he insists he's
fighting to provide basic services for
the people that Isabel matin in the
capital Port-au-Prince
analyze lies just one of the many gangs
vying for control of photo prints but
the places where Jedi family it is run
by former police officer Jeremy
sherisier also known as barbecue he took
us to the front line of his Urban
Battleground he says a rival gang is on
the other side
it's unfortunate we have to call some
Haitians enemies but the Haitian
oligarchs and politicians give them guns
and ammunition to destroy our
communities his men are extremely
cautious wary of an attack from the
other side
has created what is known as the G9 it's
a Federation of gangs and it's one of
the most powerful here in the capital
they're fighting for control of the
territory on the other side of this wall
is the neighborhood of Bel-Air that
they've been trying to control
but shiricia says the G9 is not a gang
he says he's fighting to help provide
security and basic services to the
people left behind by the government
there's a difference between a gang and
an armed group we have an ideology we
have a vision to see Haiti with all the
services with drinkable water Schools
jobs and with security
his opponents accuse his groups of
killing civilians and setting houses on
fire hundreds have fled fearing for
their lives the U.N U.S and Canada
impose sanctions on him last year
prime minister arielenry has asked for
international assistance to fight the
gangs
says most are funded by those running
the country
the PM's not asking for foreign troops
to come to the country they want foreign
forces to protect them from the crimes
they have committed several times the
un's intervened in Haiti and you see
that the result is always zero
wanted to show us the difference between
the areas controlled by him and other
parts of Porto Prince
he says there are no shortages of food
here and the streets are clean because
he pays for it
Jimmy is the state in this part of
Port-au-Prince
in the past few weeks people have turned
against the gangs in the country killing
suspected gang members on the streets
the movement is known as guacame
says he supports them saying the time
has come for people to fight back
okay I want to take you back to our
earlier developing story Ecuador's
president Guillermo lasso has dissolved
Congress we're going to talk to
Alessandro rampieti who's in Ecuador's
Capital Quito so Alessandro what happens
now
yes Rob what happens now essentially is
that immediately uh the National
Assembly the Ecuador's Congress is
closed the police has already been
deployed to block the entrance for
lawmakers that were expected to continue
the impeachment proceedings on on
Wednesday these were supposed to start
in one hour instead nobody is allowed to
enter a congress right now we've seen
the police standing in front of the main
doors of the building and the next thing
that will happen is that the national
electoral Council will have 90 days to
call and present new presidential and
parliamentary elections so the country
will likely have a new president as soon
as August in case somebody wins in the
first round or it could instead have to
wait until November in the meantime
president guillermolasso will be able to
govern by decree with the Constitutional
Court having essentially
uh to work as a control mechanism for
the degrees that he will present he
already presented one a new fiscal law
that will reduce taxes for a great
number of ecuadorians so that will be
the situation for at least the next uh
four months uh lasso announced this in a
pre-recorded National address that was
then broadcast at 7am local here he was
surrounded by his ministers and said
that this was a legal and Democratic way
to solve what he called a useless
confrontation between the executive
power and the legislative power in the
country Alessandro he might be calling
it a useless confrontation but the
allegations are serious he's been
accused of corruption he's being
impeached what does this mean for the
impeachment process and any subsequent
legal process that might go on
well this essentially means that the
impeachment process is over and the
truth is that while obviously these were
serious charges this went beyond this
particular case and what we've seen now
for months in the country was sort of a
game of brickmanship between the
executive power and the legislative
power with the legislative power in the
country working to try and remove the
president he had already faced an
impeachment trial less than a year ago
following a massive protests in the
country on the price of living
ecuadorians here very tired about not
only the worsening economic situation
but also at the graded security
situation for many years Ecuador was a
relatively Safe Haven in Latin America
but recently it has become the main
transport hub for
drug trafficking the drug trafficking of
cocaine to the United States and and to
Europe This has brought high levels of
violence here in the capital Quito and
especially along uh the coast so people
were very tired here a lot of them were
accusing the president of being unable
to control the situation in in the
country lasso says that though he wasn't
allowed to govern because the opposition
majority in Congress essentially was
blocking all his legislative agendas
Alessandra rampieti and keto Alessandra
thank you very much indeed
anymore